they're like oh it's okay
what was a female judge probation
i think we all have this natural
instinct to protect girls and i think
girls kind of have it too oh girls have
a natural instinct guys have a natural
instinct to protect girls and girls have
a natural instinct to protect themselves
but i understand that it's a it's an
evolutionary thing
because
well physically women are
the weaker sex on a general basis
so it was very important for them
their survival came more from
social skills and being selfish
in terms of looking out for their own
needs as opposed to sacrificing for
others that's what men did
that's true but sometimes
it just irritates me because i think
that's why girls get away with so much
stuff
yeah i think it's it's starting to
change though yeah well especially with
the red pill yeah i think i think the
red pill is gonna change a lot of things
oh yeah and men's rights and that's
starting to become more mainstream oh
100 i mean purely because of red people
like less men wouldn't get married
yeah
that's true or maybe that's the courts
well and it's so
it sucks that it's such a big risk for
guys what marriage yeah because they
could
lose half their money yeah i i had to
have a conversation with my parents and
be like i don't know if i'll actually
ever get married i was like i'll have a
long time partner
but there may never be a wedding for you
to come to when it comes to me oh my
gosh my parents would kill me if i ever
said that
i think of the same thing though
sometimes actually
time's different because
but i'm a woman so i probably i will but
yeah
[Laughter]
all the guys in there they're like yeah
[ __ ] accept it
what are they thinking don't be like all
these other hoes
who like if you're not under six three i
don't even see you
i wouldn't make that card i'm 62. and
i'm like i thought i was tall enough
okay kit
oh go on am i getting some hate yeah
you'd be talking like a simp sometimes
he's an actual gentleman but where do
you draw the line what do you what do
you have to say to the people that think
you're a stamp
if i only union
[Music]
listen i let other people
i let the results speak for themselves
um i'm a bit like um i'm not allowed you
know if i'm allowed to compliment well
because i'm complimenting pearl all
right [ __ ] it you can say that okay but
we're friends i'm allowed to compliment
my friend okay do you think that
um
men should be weary of a woman's past
because
well like for example with kim and kanye
like kanye clearly was not weary of her
past
do you think well he also knew you just
didn't care yeah that's what i'm saying
he white he wifed the thought like do
you if you were advising men
would you say
to like go digging see what see what
she's been up to uh
this is interesting it's interesting
because you coach women mostly right
yeah and you probably tell the girls
like do not
no i do not tell him anything no i don't
say that why what i kind of i say what
you you said to um amy when she came on
as in
you can choose what you want to do but
these are the potential consequences of
your actions as long as you understand
that
do you
so should a guy go digging
i mean digging sounds a bit controlling
or extensive not digging but
you think you should ask like who like
about her what she's done before or no
i would say if he if he has to ask
because if she's really out there he
would probably know but i guess that
depends on how you meet her doesn't it
because if you know her through social
circles you probably know some of her
dirt
but if you met her online you probably
wouldn't know any
should he ask
because kim's public but stuff happens
between guys like kanye and girls like
kim all the time yeah
he's a here's the thing right i think
for guys
a lot of it is about respect
and if she did some 30 [ __ ] but no one
knew
i don't i think that's
because if she's because it means that
respect
for her
is important which means it's going to
be important for him
but
if she was out there and she didn't care
who knew he's like oh i like her but to
everyone else this wouldn't look good
for me
so
i think it's how she handles her past
really because everyone's gonna have a
pass this is 20 22. like
let's get real
interesting especially attractive girls
they're gonna they're gonna call you a
samp
i've never cared what people think
uh that's interesting because i would
tell my brother well would you rather
have a would you rather have a virgin
are you mad
you're silly if anything got any
guidance
from marriage any guy today
i'll say it on my chest any guy today
who wants a virgin
today
you clearly don't care about having
great sex clearly i don't know because
you're
numbered from my experience numbers-wise
okay yeah a girl that's a virgin and
gets married you know what her
percentage chance of having a happy
marriage is it's probably higher it's
like a lot higher yeah but let me ask
you this
you know a guy who has sex with a virgin
uh-huh do you know the chance of him
having great sex with her is
[Music]
it's not that high have you had sex with
a virgin i've had sex with
close to a virgin
when she was a virgin or she wasn't she
wasn't a virgin she she was very
sexually inexperienced and she was a
lovely person um it sounds like i'm
being hard she was a lovely person but i
it was the worst sex ever you can like
teach her
nah i'm not here for that man come on
now you better come correct
no i'm joking
um i could but
i think if i was looking for marriage
and certainly down maybe it wouldn't
have been that much of a thing but i'm
just not there yet because for me like i
don't think sex is that big of a deal in
a relationship um kevin samuels was
talking about this
for a woman it's not for a guy it's
important
oh for a guy yeah because if we're gonna
call if we're not going to accept sex
from anywhere else
you're the sense we have better be
minimum satisfactory minimum i was
talking to this about some i was taught
this about uh a female friend was asking
me for some dating about oh this was
yesterday last night right and i was
like when men and women get into a
relationship
we make different compromises
the woman's compromise is i will not
even if a better option comes along
loyalty from me is me not leaving you
for that better option
law
the compromise men make is i will not
have sex with any other girl because we
know when guys are just looking for sex
their standards are much lower
so like a guy who's an a would easily
have sex with a six seven or a five
right and he probably gets five and
sixes putting it on the plate for him
that's what his compromise is he's like
i will not have sex with these girls and
her compromise is i will not leave you
for a better option
which means if he's going to be
compromising on having sexual variety
which is instinctually what men
do want
the sex he is getting better be good
it doesn't have to be amazing it doesn't
have to be the best
but it has to be
satisfactory minimum
there was a guy
that i met at
a pickup conference okay a pickup
conference i went to a pickup conference
for a youtube video
okay yeah i like i wanted to see what
all the men were talking about you know
yeah
yeah um and so it was like john anthony
lifestyle
i had him on my channel just because i
had a lot of men's subscribers so i was
like
tell tell the boys how to get the
[ __ ] you know i find this on his
channel is so cringe man i don't know um
but he has um
he has a boot camp that he runs where
like guys pay thousands of dollars to go
learn how to get laid if you
want to make money as a dating coach
okay i s that's just not my vibe i get
it
but when i i'm about more than it's like
it's like it's like
it's pretty good
that's pretty good actually you know
what
actually
that's what i said but um when i went
through these guys think i'm a simple
they think i don't get girls they um
at the at the pickup conference they
i asked um
he told me the best like one of the guys
that ran it not john anthony lifestyle
but he was like
basically a big man [ __ ] like i saw him
take home like a different girl every
single day he was he was good at what he
did i saw the results right yeah and um
he told me the best sex he ever had was
with like a 45 year old
i believe that
are you speaking from experience
yeah
i believe it
oh my gosh